d'autres profitez-en parce que ces gens
n'aient jamais revenir hypocrite comme
un constat pas la grosse tête avec tout
ce qui t'arrive parce que tu es quand
même assez jeune tu vas quand même un
bon succès auprès auprès de tout le
monde je me brosse peut-être pourrai-je
elle assume pleinement
c'est quelque chose que je puisse bien
tous les matins sous le nom sa salle à
manger avant la grossesse est passé cela
raconté mais qu'elle allait revoir et
bon oui on a réussi donc on considère
que les autres sont inférieurs on y
traite pas de la même façon que j'ai au
monde sait ça c'est sincèrement pour
l'instant non mais sachez une chose et
je préviens tous mes proches que si par
malheur je vais tourner un jour aux
states à los angeles où elle le locle
c'est la merde pour vous parce que là je
vais la prendre et sans pitié